Till I got choked out 10 years ago that I think about some times when I'm
lifting,
I'll be tired and I'll think about a guy who caught me 10 years of my life.
Fuck.
That's what's big about life man.
Cause I think about not being choked out.
I think about a lot of shit like that.
Yeah,
just keep pushing.
They grind them.
We like a motherfucker man.
And that's what you're talking about earlier too.
It's like the mind has these reserves.
You can trick it and pull him out.
He's inspirational reserves like you did with when,
when you,
when you guys were going through buds.
Yes.
We just found that trigger and then all of a sudden you throw in that boat in
the air.
The mind always has to tactical advantage over you.
Why is it it knows your fear.
Ours and noisy insecurities.
It knows where their height and you can't hide.
You can't hide that motherfucker,
man am I forget the tactical barriers on your son that's going to get you man.
It's a beast.
That might be best lesson,
right?
That your mind,
your mind knows everything.
You cannot hide from it,
so don't ever try it.
Don't try.
It might as well go ahead and beat that motherfucker.
Got to keep going at it.
That's also what you did in this book.
You didn't try to like paint yourself in a glamorous or flattering way at any
point in time.
You were honest at every step of the way,
which I think is just gigantic for people too because you can tell when
someone's stroking themselves are bullshitting themselves and is the message
just won't come through.
Right,
but this your you come through in this book,
you know like who you are and what you became and how you became who you are and
who you used to be and why you were the way you used to be.
All that comes through.
It's like there's no filter.
This is just your,
your thoughts like you,
what you remember about your life and what you think about right now.
Just all comes out onto the pages.
Hardest thing I've done my entire life.
I'm a manager.
I have fucking,
I don't know how to go buy this book.
Then I walk up to people.
People walk up to me.
I was like,
what are you thinking about motherfucker,
thank puppy peed in the bed and was fucking ass.
When you're thinking about,
oh that's hilarious.
I know,
right?
Like you like thinking about me opening it up.
All you know all about me.
How about you motherfuckers?
Tell me something about you.
That's what people love,
right?
When they know some shit about you and you don't know nothing about them,
nothing about nobody.
That's anonymous trolls it man,
they get at me that co there's a lot of those but that they're all doing that to
themselves.
They don't even understand when you do that,
you're doing it to yourself.
Right.
If you are attacking someone cause you know that they have a weakness but you're
pretending you don't have one,
you are attacking yourself.
You are chipping away at your own personal sovereignty,
chipping away at your own respect.
So true man.
Can't respect yourself.
You're a pussy.
You're talking.
Shit happened though Joe.
To me,
I started looking at people realizing I know something about you
because they don't want to talk about it.
Right.
I already know it.
Yeah.
If you're talking about me.
Yeah,
I know you're fucked up.
Yeah.
That's what all these cats that come out right now who don't like me,
whatever.
I'm like,
really man,
this should happen 30 fucking years ago.
15 years ago.
You're still,
you're still fucked up about that.
Oh man,
I know something about you brother.
Does that get over everything?
I'm good.
It's water under the fucking bridge grind.
The grind does that.
That's it.
You're not grinding harder.
If you're worried about something that someone did to you years ago,
you're being a pussy to yourself.
May Not getting out there in squeezing that fucking soul out every day.
If you grind hard,
and I got ton of,
we're about your monkey ass.
I gotta tell him about you man.
Cause tomorrow I got to go back to the grind and tomorrow I go back to the grind
again and again and again and again.
I don't have time to put you into the Haight Bank.
There's no hate.
It's all filtered out,
man,
through the grind.
If you don't get it,
there's,
there's great joy in the grind,
great Jordan and suffer.
It's totally cleanses your body out,
man.
If any kind of hate it makes you grow up.